where I was at the table and JLo
actually handed her phone to Ben and
said hey honey look at this meme that's
circulating about you so they were so
well aware during the Grammys about it
yeah benefit allegedly well aware of his
trending status at the Grammy Awards can
you see if we can get in the papers
because I'm trying to get more publicity
you got it Ben because the fans got
obsessed with moments like these no no
Mom no Mom it wasn't the actual devil no
they were just dressed as the devil mom
they don't yeah no I have to go yeah
yeah you did warn me about Hollywood one
person joked however bad of a day you're
having I promise you're not as miserable
as Ben Affleck at the Grammys right now
you know it's wild to think about it
that way Days Later someone is speaking
out on the cliffo and Bronte podcast
sharing their alleged eyewitness details
and it's funny actually that you talked
about Ben Affleck because I was sitted
seated right next to him the guest
claims to have been a Jen and Ben's
table on the job as a seed filler people
hired to step in for celebs when they're
not seated a common practice at award
shows there's going to be seat fillers
down in the front row if we linger here
they're A-list chairs Dwayne Johnson and
wife Lauren we took the rock seat
button up so my friend Jake and I just
jumped into those seats The Rock turned
to us and said you better not talk to
them that's kind of a joke to me and
Jake about JLo
um and we just looked at each other like
oh my gosh and that was the only time
that
um a celebrity talked directly to us how
can you tell if someone's a seat filler
they wore ribbons just like the one this
person next to Ben is wearing and in a
now private Tick Tock post from the
podcast guest they did look pretty
similar of course one thing we can't
confirm is their inside scoop
I was at the table
table actually handed her phone to Ben
and said hey honey look at this meme
that's circulating about you what else
they claimed Jennifer wasn't mad and she
even spread the word it
texting I I didn't know who but she was
texting people about the meme and
sending it to her friends and Ben's
reaction
I think he just laughed it off this
comes amid speculation of what the
newlyweds are saying here well ET hired
a lip reader to help everyone out
look more friendly
and then look motivate it Ben allegedly
responds I might oh I give it away but
it has a very good ending as for et's
Insider on Grammy's night no Deets on
that combo but we're hearing Ben was
feeling tired but he still wanted to
support Jen The Source adds despite the
memes they still made it a fun date
night that tracks with JLo's caption on
the gram her final word on the night
always the best time with my love my
husband we're super happy
um what can I tell you
[Music]
foreign